welcome everybody to the second robot
simulations video using the isaac sim in
nvidia's omniverse in this video i'll
share my experiences with attempting to
use various algorithms to train the
biddle robot dog to walk while the
stampede of biddles that you're seeing
now is indeed a reinforcement learning
algorithm that finally worked getting
here was mostly a journey of this
and this
this this
this
and this what's going on is i'm
attempting to have a machine learning
algorithm learn to move the middle robot
forward this forward movement can be
referred to as a forward gate in many
quadruped robots this movement the gate
is actually hand coded such as the
forward gate of the actual bit of robot
but what i want to do is see if i can
use machine learning to learn a gate as
much as media or even tutorials like to
demonstrate machine learning as a thing
where you just simply import deep
learning and everything just works out
of the box this is very far from reality
so how do i actually approach a problem
like this where there isn't already some
super clear answer or the problem isn't
very simple simplify the problem itself
to start let's cut the number of servos
in half and use an environment that's
much quicker to iterate with by using
the bipedal walker environment from the
openai gym this environment is similar
to the one that we want to solve where
the objective is to walk forward without
falling by controlling servos and the
servo positions are continuous rather
than categorical and what do we mean
here
take an environment like cartpole where
the goal is to balance the pull on the
cart by moving the cart left or right
here the cart is merely moved with
actions of 0 or 1 which correspond to
left or right
leg servos however are in a range of
something like negative 1 to positive
one for example
so rather than just two choices of left
or right we have theoretically infinite
choices of servo positions between
negative one and positive one because of
this this is a substantially different
problem than the typical dpq learning
where the output is a probability
distribution of some categorical actions
and what we want instead as the output
is individual continuous values for each
of the servos with the obvious intention
that they will all work in unison to get
the robot dog to walk now i'm pretty
weak in the area of reinforcement
learning and i've never run an algorithm
with continuous output for reinforcement
learning so i poked around for various
control
algorithms for specifically continuous
control
and i found ddpg or deep deterministic
policy gradient and actor critic style
algorithm for reinforcement learning
with continuous control problems
okay so that covers our outputs but what
about our inputs while we obviously need
a model that can output what we want the
input to the model is of some importance
too i'd say so what inputs do we
actually require for an agent to learn
to walk the bipedal walker has lidar
ground contact senses motor position and
velocity as well as hole angle and
velocity that's a lot of information
some of which on the physical biddle we
just simply don't have like lidar or
ground contact sensing and our version
of whole angle is similar but it's
different can we still learn to walk
without those luxuries
with deep reinforcement learning
answering questions like these can take
time especially when it comes to well
what combination of sensory information
do we absolutely need if tests take
hours or days or more this can be a real
problem
enter the lovely neat or neural
evolution of augmenting topology's
algorithm i've grown to really love the
neat algorithm as a proof of concept if
you missed it i did a video on the neat
algorithm a bit ago and it's worth
checking out for pretty much anybody
because you don't need a fancy gpu to
use it the beauty of neat is how
extremely fast it can learn things from
my experience with neat if neat can
learn something so if something's really
complicated like these very large
language models
neat would never learn something like
that but if if it's a problem that's
simple enough that neat can learn it it
will usually learn it within a few
minutes to a few hours at most
and then if neat does actually learn
something this is basically a guarantee
that a more traditional gradient descent
deep learning algorithm can also learn
it and probably do it much better it
might take a whole lot longer but at
least you will embark on that journey of
time having a pretty good reason to
believe that something can be learned
here to put this in perspective let's
compare the training and running of the
neat algorithm and ddpg on the bipedal
walker what you see now is a slightly
sped up 90 seconds of training the neat
algorithm
so what did we learn in those 90 seconds
well this isn't the most graceful
walking we've ever seen it's definitely
walking and what if we trained for an
extra 30 seconds again still not the
smoothest walking we've ever seen but it
is very stable and it's pretty much
solved the environment
and this took two minutes
now let's compare that to ddbg here we
have a 45 minute training session where
we're showing the exploit only agent
every 10 episodes so we can actually see
visually the walker definitely improves
to a maximum that is both slightly
better in terms of score than the two
minute need algorithm as well as it just
visually looks better more like it's
actually running but then the ddpg
algorithm loses everything and gets
silly again and never seems to recover
apparently this is fairly common
behavior for the ddpg algorithm to reach
a peak and then lose it but by this
point i have enough information to at
least start taking some swings with the
isaac sim and biddle rather than
continuing to play around and figure out
this environment instead around this
time i got a care package from puget
equipped with two rtx 3090s a terabyte
in ram and a 32 core 64 thread beast of
a cpu from intel i know right at this
instant you might be wondering what in
the heck would we possibly use all that
ram for well for now not all that much
our input observations are very basic
features but eventually we may want to
include video input as well since the
actual physical biddle does have an
option for a camera on the front and
with that pretty much all of these
reinforcement learning algorithms use
what's called memory and that memory
contains observations among other things
the standard size of that memory is 1
million observations so if we have 1
million images in there or even 1
million groups of images we need a ton
of memory other than that the puget
machine has enabled some extremely fast
speedups in my training both in running
the actual simulator as well as training
the model the rtx 3090 cards are
freaking awesome for machine learning so
for initial results we have a whole lot
of nothing for a ddpg i actually never
once got anything truly usable from ddpg
now this is pretty indicative of
realistic deep learning where if there's
not already some sort of pre-made
solution it can often take quite a while
before you get anything that starts to
work
and it's just a lot of trial and error
so initially both algorithms both ddpg
and the neat algorithm did a whole lot
of this like jittery sliding stuff this
signals to me that there's certainly
some physics tweaking that we're gonna
have to figure out in the future and
this really just seems to me more like
the agent has learned to exploit the
environment
so possibly this is something to address
in the future but i also went ahead and
just wrote a fail safe to stop this from
happening so if joints uh on the whole
if more than like five joints for
example don't move enough then the
reward is negative one regardless of
what actually happens in the sim so it's
sort of a punishment for this like
jittery slide thing that it's doing and
then in general i'm rewarding biddles
for forward movement only minus any side
to side movement
and i'm doing this reward relatively per
step
beyond the slide hack i also had
variations learn things like jumping or
even cooler this sort of
short term jump and roll thing
the problem here is this produced very
short term gains in reward but then the
model could never recover from learning
that behavior
the first semi-successful algorithm
finally worked and unsurprisingly it was
the neat algorithm there's definitely
something very curious about how the
neat algorithm continues to come up with
these very silly looking gates but they
work the best of the ddpg algorithm was
here which is obviously quite terrible
and far worse than the neat algorithm
and a little too slightly for my tastes
now that neat algorithm example is
interesting especially the way it like
swings one of the legs around for the
distribution of of weight
uh and i'm totally tempted to put that
on the physical biddle but i want to
approach that problem when i have
something else to test as well besides
that one because something tells me that
that won't go well but it would be funny
to see it on the actual physical biddle
and if it did work that it would just be
really cool to see
but we still need a solution that is
better than
arguably both of these so then i turned
my sights to td3 an evolved version of
ddpg but didn't see any initial gains
there either and at this point i'm
starting to lose hope like maybe i'm not
using valuable enough inputs maybe
there's a bug in my code but i'm
confused by this because the neat
algorithm
did actually learn was that a fluke did
i just get lucky right now i'm only
using servo positions along with
rotational position deltas from the
starting position and i'm starting to
wonder if possibly i'm misunderstanding
the pose.r method in the isaac sim like
all intelligent deep learning
researchers at this point i began the
shotgun approach
i'll spare you the many different models
that i tried but then finally something
i tried actually worked i increased the
model size and the number of layers and
finally a model bit
at least for a little while now the
default is not a small model and i just
kind of thought that the default size
was a pretty good size if anything i
felt like we could probably make a
smaller model work but regardless the
larger model is indeed what worked and
at least for a little while it worked
anyways this is a the graph shape that
i've been seeing very frequently of
reward uh from a model and training of
the ddpg variant there's this bump in
learning things are going really well
and then the model just loses it all
i've attempted to change hyper
parameters for the actual networks and
the update rates noise all kinds of
things i've tried
everything
and i've even tried taking a model at
that high peak and then changing some of
the hyper parameters like the update
rate for example just so hopefully it
wouldn't update itself back to stupidity
but that has not helped so the current
best result that i've seen is by leaving
everything the same as it was in the
original td 3 paper the only significant
change here is bumping the original
actor and critic model sizes from being
three layers of 400 than 300 300 units
to being four layers of 512
to three 256 unit layers and just in
case you want to grab the code and make
changes yourself or apply this to one of
your projects the code that i was using
was not my own it was from the following
github repository
which has a bunch of examples of
applying
td td3 and ddpg to
in this case pi bullet sims stuff but
basically open ai gem
so you can use this code to apply this
to pretty much any simulator uh that
kind of follows that that structure or
that paradigm basically of you know
getting an observation taking a step
action based on that observation getting
the reward and so on so anyways if
you're interested in doing this sort of
thing whether it's in isaac sim or on
some other environment uh this is a
pretty good place to start there's lots
of great examples and it's pretty easy
to tweak and read the code from here so
anyway can't recommend this one enough
the result of these changes is what you
saw initially at the opening of the
video i've of course done some further
tests to see if i can improve quickly
from here by adding more layers or more
units per layer nothing substantial yet
but this is definitely the new baseline
that i will continue working from so if
you'd like to try to tackle this problem
and maybe work from my baseline or make
your own entirely i've gone ahead and
uploaded some files that i think might
be useful to you so
i've left a little bit of a list here
but i'll also go through everything
myself so i've got the scene files that
i'm using those should go inside of your
isaac directory in the nucleus
i've also got the best model so far the
trained model is up here
if you want to use that and then also
the
uh the actual uh
neural network model is also uploaded
here as long as well as the original so
if you want to work from the actual
original and try other things or you
know come up with your own version
that's totally fine
and probably the big thing if you want
to play it you can play it but it's just
going to be the video that you saw
essentially
and if you want to train it this is the
training file here so we can kind of run
through essentially this is just me
hacking in
the working uh the using the isaac sim
in place of the open ai gym environment
so it's kind of messy there might be
some redundancy here there might even be
errors here so
feel free to look through it submit prs
if you think that there's something that
can be improved or i'm doing something
wrong
if you're just looking for something to
do probably the first thing i would look
at is right here pose.r i part of me
thinks that either this should be maybe
relative pose.r
or
maybe pose dart order isn't even what i
think it is so like i'm not sure if it's
in relation to the actual plane and then
each biddle has its own plane anyway
that's a spot that someone could start
with but anyways we've got some basic
starting um constants here whether or
not we want to load a model so we can
train from that pre-trained model if we
as long as we keep everything the same
um like in terms of the model that we're
going to train from and so on um and
then uh we've got max steps you can
increase this or decrease this if you
want uh this here is for tracking that
kind of wiggle basically how we're just
trying to make sure a standard deviation
is high enough uh in the movements how
many random episodes is how many
episodes do we want to start with
where we're not really trying to use the
agent's model at all we're just randomly
moving
this would be another thing you could
try to tinker with maybe do more random
episodes this is your memory buffer one
million is just the standard i have
tried to do three million five million
uh and then even smaller like five
hundred thousand nothing really seems to
make a difference max total reward i
think this would be a redundant thing i
don't actually think it's even being
used
biddle count you you might find that the
biddles are stepping really really
slowly so you might want to decrease
this or increase this i the files that i
have have 20 biddles if i recall right
so you can use any number from 1 to 20.
coming down
these are just some of the
things from the original td 3 script you
can change those if you want lots of
lots of things to tweak here like
exploration noise discount tau all this
stuff like you could definitely
tweak that
these are just the hard-coded values if
you wind up having more of an
observation something else in the
observation you're going to want to add
that because i've just hard coded this
the action dimensions this is just how
many servos that we have i don't think
that's going to change at all ever max
action this might actually be somewhat
variable i forget i think it might even
go up to like 1.3 it's like some some
odd range so i just went with 1.1 so
that could be probably tweaked
uh let's see then we load in the model
we're just setting some information for
the isaac sim here
uh and then we're just going to start
iterating over the episodes themselves
uh if we're doing random cool we're
doing random some are isaac sims stuff
we go ahead and start up the isaac sim
and then basically this is just the
initial whenever a scene gets set up
making some dictionaries here this is
because we're running multiple biddles
but we're actually running a single
multiple biddles in a single environment
so the way that we're going to do this
is for every step we're going to iterate
over every single biddle but as we
iterate over the biddles the way that
these things are architected is
essentially you want to be able to
get your observation
come up with your action
and then all of the biddles need to take
that action so so what i'm doing is
iterating over all of the biddles here
we're actually taking the action but
then before we can train the model we
need to go ahead and step the
environment so kit.update is essentially
that step
and then we're going to iterate over all
of the biddles again
getting their reward essentially from
this point so i calculate the total
reward based on the delta from their car
their their starting position to their
current and then i'm subtracting any x
so any side to side movement we're just
subtracting that and then in this case i
to be honest i already forgot that i
even divided by 10 here but apparently
apparently i'm doing that so anyway you
you can you can use this and and tweak
from here i have tried to not divide by
10 as well uh like i said i didn't even
remember that was in there but that is
what i used for the best performance so
far so anyway um you can try to tweak
this come up with your own different
rewards maybe you want to scale rewards
more like the the bigger steps maybe you
want those to be exponentially
more rewarding or something so you feel
free to tweak the total reward that's
probably the most or not the total
reward necessarily but the actual reward
in this case will be the
uh the delta from the previous where was
the biddle previously to where is it now
that's kind of that's the relative
reward per step so then coming down here
this is my fail safe essentially uh what
i'm doing is making sure we have enough
in that that so we don't have like just
one movement but then we're going to
check the standard deviation of all of
the movements if that standard deviation
is less than that movement for enough of
the servos in this case more than uh
well five or more
if that is the case then we're going to
say the reward is a negative one we
don't really care what that relative
movement was it's probably shaking
around so i've played with 0.1 and then
0.05
both somewhere in there is probably the
best but again
feel free to tinker with that maybe
don't even use it at all but i've tried
that as well
anyway so then we get the reward and uh
and then in this case uh let's see if
there's anything else
so in this case we're saving the
previous total reward but that's just so
we can later do the relative reward
um but here you can see the actual
reward is what we set up here so this is
what actually gets added to the memory i
forget why i threw in and if true again
like i said this is all very hacked
together at some point this probably was
actually asking uh if the biddle i used
to i was using biddle zero as the
constantly the exploit biddle and now
i'm exploiting every 10 steps or
something so anyway that's probably what
was going on there anyways
um and then after uh after we've done an
entire for each episode so we've we've
stepped over
um every step we've iterated over the
biddles we've stuffed the environment
we've iterated again over all the
biddles then we go ahead and actually
train that policy and again here this is
how many iterations do we want to train
for what is our batch size so the
default batch size was 128
but then once we add more biddles in the
environment in theory we're kind of uh
we're increasing the
number of iterations considerably so
again i've just kind of tweaked that and
tinkered around trying to figure out
what is the best way because in general
as long as you have enough data which i
think we do
um
you
are arguably rather have a larger batch
size so anyways i'm still tinkering with
that as well
printing out some just basic information
as things are training and then also
saving either the exploit reward or the
train reward over time uh which actually
just reminds me i don't have that
graphing script i don't think i uploaded
that let me check that real quick
plot results yeah so i have a plot
results
version of my own so i'll go ahead and
upload that that too as well so you can
uh graph those at live as it trains
anyway that's all for now hopefully the
next time you guys hear from me i will
have something even more impressive up
to this point
if you guys want to issue fixes prs
whatever or maybe you can come up with
something even better than me let me
know
otherwise thanks for watching and i will
see you all in another video
you